>>> I'M PAMELA BROWN IN
WASHINGTON.
YOU ARE IN THE "CNN NEWSROOM" ON
THIS SATURDAY.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH BREAKING
NEWS OUT OF THE UK.
S THAT WHERE A NEW GOVERNMENT
REPORT SAYS VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
LOOKING TO INSTALL A PRO-RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT IN UKRAINE AS THE
KREMLIN CONSIDERS WHETHER TO
INVADE AND POSSIBLY OCCUPY THAT
COUNTRY.
A MEMO FROM THE BRITISH FOREIGN
OFFICE SAYS MOSCOW MAY BE
CONSIDERING A FORMER UKRAINIAN
POLITICIAN AS A CANDIDATE TO
LEAD THE PUPPET GOVERNMENT.
TENSIONS BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE HAVE BEEN GROWING FOR
MONTHS AS MOSCOW BUILT UP A
SIZABLE TROOP PRESENCE AT THE
BORDER LEAVING MANY TO FEAR AN
INVASION WAS COMING.
CNN'S NIC ROBERTSON IS IN
MOSCOW.
WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW WITH THIS?
>> THIS IS THE BRITISH
GOVERNMENT SAYING THAT THE
KREMLIN IS CURRENTLY CONSIDERING
TO INSTALL A PRO-RUSSIAN
LEADERSHIP IN UKRAINE TO REPLACE
THE EXISTING ONE AS THEY ARE
TOWARDS A PRO FORMA, PRO-RUSSIAN
POLITICIAN LOOKING TOWARDS TO
INSTALL AS THE NEW LEADER OF
UKRAINE.
NOW, CNN HAS REACHED OUT AND
CONTACTED HIM AND HE SAID, LOOK,
THERE IS NO COMMENT TO MAKE
HERE, PAUSE I AM ON A RUSSIAN
SANCTION LEST.
SO HIS IMPLICATION IS HOW COULD
I POSSIBLY BE DOING SOMETHING
FOR THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
HOW COULD THEY PROBABLY HAVE ME?
PAUSE THEY ALREADY HAVE ME UNDER
SANCTIONS.
THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT HAS GONE
FURTHER.
THEY'VE NAMED FOUR OTHER PEOPLE,
A FORMER PRIME MINISTER, TWO
FORMER DEPUTY PRIME MINISTERS
AND FORMER SECURITY OFFICIAL WHO
MAY SAY THEY HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE OPERATIVES.
THOSE OPERATIVES THE BRITISH
GOVERNMENT SAYS ARE THOSE
PLANNING THE POSSIBLE INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
SO THIS IS VERY STRONG LANGUAGE,
A VERY SPECIFIC NAMING BY THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT HERE.
THE BRITISH FOREIGN SECRETARY
SAYS THIS GIVES AN INDICATION OF
THE THINKING THAT IS GOING AN
AND ASSESSING AT THE MOMENT?
YEAH, I SPOKE TO A BRITISH
SECURITY FORCE AROUND ASKED, WHY
ARE YOU PUTTING THIS OUT THERE,
ALL THE INFORMATION YOU KNOW.
I WAS TOLD THE STRATEGY IS
BASICALLY TO SEND THE MESSAGE TO
RUSSIA AND ALSO TO THE PUBLIC,
LOOK, WE KNOW WHAT YOU ARE UP TO
AND TO GET OUT ON THE FRONT FOOT
AS THIS PERSON SAID.
IN THE MEANTIME, ALL THIS IS
GOING ON, THE U.S. EMBASSY HAS
SENT ITS FIRST SECURITY
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE, SOME
200,000 LETHAL AID, INCLUDING
AMMUNITION FOR FRONT HALLOWEEN
DEFENDERS.
IS THERE ANY CONCERN THAT CAN
PROVOKE RUSSIA EVEN MORE ON
LAVROV'S INVASION UNLESS THE
U.S. GOES TO BED WITH UKRAINE,
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN?
>> THIS IS COMING FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE WAS VIDEO FOOTAGE OF THIS
IN THE AIRPORT IN UKRAINE WHEN
IT LANDED.
SO THERE IS A BIG EFFORT ON TO
SHOW A PUPPET SHOW OF THIS WE
ARE'ING IN LOCKSTEP BY THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT NAMING THESE
FWROUP GROUP OF PEOPLE AND PUT
THEM ON NOTICE THAT THEY BELIEVE
WHAT THEY ARE PLANNING HERE.
IT IS A PART OF A PACKAGE TO
SEND A MESSAGE TO PRESIDENT
PUTIN TO MAKE HIM THINK TWICE
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL OF INVASION.
IT'S NOT ONLY THAT U.S. MILITARY
AID ARRIVED TODAY.
WE KNOW THE ESTONEIAN GOVERNMENT
IS SENDING JAVELIN MISSILES.
THE STINGER MISSILE SYSTEM PUT
AGAINST HELICOPTERS AND
LOW-FLYING JETS.
THEY ARE ANNOUNCING THE CZECH
GOVERNMENT WILL SEND AMMUNITION
FOR ARTILLERY.
THE GERMAN GOVERNMENT ANNOUNCED
THEY WILL SEND A FIELD HOSPITAL,
A MILITARY FIELD HOSPITAL, SO
ALL OF THESE THINGS, IT IS VERY
PUBLIC AND IT'S DONE WITH THAT
PRECISE EFFORT.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THIS IS
THE MOMENT PRESIDENT PUTIN IS
ISRAELI REALLY CONSIDERING WHAT
NAY ARE PUTTING IN PLACE AS WHAT
THEY PUT UP WILL BE THE PROBLEMS
DOWN THE ROAD, IF HE DOES THAT.
>> NIC ROBERTSON IN MOSCOW,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> THE NEWS INFORMATION FROM
THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT COMPOUNDS
THE ALREADY GROWING TENSION
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND UKRAINE.
SO WHERE DO THINGS NO FROM HERE?
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
UNITED STATES?
JOINING ME NOW, RETIRED ARMY
LEIUTENANT GENERAL AND CNN
ANALYST MARK HERTLING AND JOSH
ROGAN, GENERAL, LET'S START WITH
YOU, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS
REPORT FROM THE UK?
>> IT'S A GREAT REPORT, PAMELA.
WHAT I'LL SAY IS RUSSIA USES
MULTIPLE TYPES OF COVERT AND
OVER ATTACKS AND MANEUVER
OPTION, THAT THEY HOPE WILL
CAUSE DIVISIVENESS IN ANY
COUNTRY THEY ARE LOOKING TO
PERSUADE TO TO OR INFLUENCE TO
TO WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO.
NONE OF THIS IS NEW OR UNUSUAL.
MOST COUNTRIES IN EUROPE, MONTE
NEGRO, LITHUANIA WILL TELL YOU
THAT THEY HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE IN
THESE TYPES OF AREAS.
WITHOUT DIVULGING DETAILS, I
USED TO RECEIVE INTELLIGENCE
ABOUT THIS KIND OF THING AS THE
COMMANDER OF U.S. ARMY EUROPE.
AND YOUR QUESTION A MINUTE AGO
ABOUT WHY ARE THEY PUTTING THIS
OUT THERE NOW?
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
IT'S ON THE MARK.
BECAUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITIES
USED TO KEEP THESE THINGS CLOSE
HOLD.
BUT NOW THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION, THIS PUBLICATION OF
INFORMATION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST WHAT RUSSIA IS DOING.
BECAUSE THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
USE THESE TYPES OF OPERATIONS TO
INFLUENCE.
YOU KNOW, THE MAIN ISSUE OF AN
ATTACK THAT WE HAVE ALL BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT IS JUST ONE OF
THE MANY THINGS THAT THEY CAN
DO.
THERE IS ASYMMETRIC WARFARE,
COVERT REPLACEMENT OF UKRAINEIAN
OFFICIALS, AIR CAMPAIGN, GROUND
MOO MANEUVERS.
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT RUSSIA IS TRYING TO
INFLUENCE NOT ONLY UKRAINE BUT
NATO AND THE U.S. AS WELL.
>> I AM CURIOUS IF YOU ARE
SEEING WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
ANNEXATION OF CRIMEA AND HOW
COUNTRIES RESPONDED TO THAT AND
CHUING THE U.S. AND HOW THEY'RE
RESPONDING TO WHAT'S GOING ON,
ON THE UKRAINIAN BORDER IF
RUSSIA.
DO YOU SEE A DIFFERENCE LIKE THE
UK LAYING OUT THE INFORMATION
THEY HAVE ON THIS PUPPET PAMELA.
ACTUALLY I SEE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE ON THE RUSSIAN SIDE
F. 2014, AS HARD AS IT WAS, THEY
NEVER WENT TO KIEV AND ENSTALLED
A RUMP GOVERNMENT WITH A FAKE
PRESIDENT.
WHICH IS WHAT THIS INTELLIGENCE
POINTS AS THEY ARE PLANNING TO
DO.
OF COURSE, IT MAY BE ONE OF MANY
PLANS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THEY WILL DO.
THE PLAN THAT THEY HAVE A PLAN
TO OCCUPY THE COUNTRY MEANS
THEIR TOLERANCE FOR PAIN MIGHT
BE A LOT HIGHER THAN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CALCULATED.
THAT'S JUST SEE UKRAINIANS AND
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON, CALLING
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO TO
MORE, WHY IS THIS THE FIRST
AMMUNITION?
WE HAVE BEEN IN THIS CRISIS HOW
MANY MONTHS?
WE JUST STARTED DROPPING OFF
AMMUNITION?
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON THE GROUND SAYING, LISTEN, WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT PUTIN WILL DO,
THE BEST WAY TO STOP THE WAR IS
INCREASING AID NOW, INCREASING
THE SANCTIONS NOW.
ONCE HE OCCUPIES KIEV, EVEN
THOUGH THE WHOLE WORLD WILL KNOW
THIS IS A CRAZY STUNT TO SNUFF
OUT UKRAINIAN DEMOCRACY, IT WILL
BE TOO LATE.
IF IT IS TO INSTALL A GOVERNMENT
AND TELL EVERYONE TO POUND SAND.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL CHANGE
BUNS THEY'VE DONE IT.
I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF REASONS
TO BE ALARMED.
>> GENERAL HERTLING, DO YOU
THINK THE FACT THAT RUSSIA IS
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS PUPPET
GOVERNMENT, DOES THAT TELL YOU
AN INVASION IS IMMINENT IN.
>> NO, I'M SURE THAT THEY WANT
TO INFLUENCE UKRAINE'S ACTION.
I'M NOT SURE THE INTELLIGENCE
THAT'S BEEN PASSED THROUGH THE
BRITISH AGENCY IS COMPLETE WITH
A LENGTH WITH A PUPPET
GOVERNMENT.
INSTEAD, I WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT
HAS THE DO WITH REPLACING
OFFICIALS IN A VERY COVERT
MANNER.
SO THAT THERE IS MORE
INTELLIGENCE COMING FROM INSIDE
UKRAINE BACK TO THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO TRY AND COMPLETELY
OVERTHROW UKRAINE'S CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT IN KIEV.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
PRESIDENT AND PARLIAMENT AND
MINISTRIES.
BUT THE RUSSIANS CERTAINLY COULD
TRY AND INFLUENCE INTELLIGENCE
PASSING AND USE PART OF WHAT
THEY CALL MOSCOW ROBOTS, THE
REDUCTION OF INTELLIGENCE WHEN
YOU CRANE BY PLACING INDIVIDUALS
IN KEY POSITIONS.
THAT'S SOMETHING RUSSIA HAS DONE
BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE
CONSIDERING RIGHT NOW THE
REPLACEMENT OF THE ENTIRE
UKRAINIAN FOST IN KIEV.
>> I WANT TO GO TO THE STATEMENT
WE JUST GOT IF FROM THE U.S.
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
EXPRESSING SOLIDARITY WITH YOU
UKRAIN THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
HAVE THE SOVEREIGN RIGHT TO
DETERMINE THEIR OWN FUTURE AND
WE STAND WITH OUR ELECTED
PARTNERS IN UKRAINE.
JOSH ROGAN, QUICKLY, IF YOU
WOULD, WHAT IS AT STAKE FOR
AMERICANS, FOR THOSE THAT MIGHT
LOOK AT THIS AND SAY, THAT'S
OVER THERE.
THAT'S BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE.
THERE IS A LOT AT STAKE, THOUGH,
FOR AMERICA, RIGHT IN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT HAPPENS IN UKRAINE DOES NOT
STAY IN UKRAINE, NOT TO MENTION
THE FACT THAT IF THERE IS A WAR
IN UKRAINE AND IF THEY OCCUPY
KIEV THAT WOULD BE A BLOODY
PANDEMIC AND REVERBERATE THROUGH
EUROPE.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS DEMOCRACY CAN
BE SNUFFED OUT IN 2022.
THAT'S A GREEN LIGHT FOR OTHER
AUTO KRATZ LIKE LET'S SAY XI
JINPING TO BELIEVE THE AMERICA
AROUND THE WEST HAS NO STOMACH
TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST THIS.
SO I THINK WHAT YOU SEE IS A
DOMINO EFFECT.
THAT WOULD HAVE REPERCUSSIONS
FIRST IN EUROPE AND AROUND THE
WORLD.
WE CAN SAY, WELL, THAT'S OVER
THERE.
IT'S REA